welcome to the presentation on adding
decimals let's do some problems so let's
say I had point zero zero eight that's
an eight eight five plus and I'm writing
it side by side on purpose one point
seven nine nine so at first you're like
these decimals they confuse me I give up
but I'm going to show you that it's
actually very straightforward and it's
actually no more difficult than doing
normal addition and there's only one
thing you have to think about when you
do decimals you have to line up the
decimal points so let's start with the
first number let's rewrite it so that we
can actually do the math point zero zero
eight five now for the second number
let's put the decimal point right below
where that first decimal is on the top
number and then rewrite the number so
it's one point seven nine nine so notice
all we did is we just rewrote both
numbers with their decimal points lined
up and we could have flipped them around
we could have written the one point
seven nine nine first and the point zero
zero eight five below it but what's key
and and if you get this point and you
already know how to do addition you've
already figured out how to do adding
decimals is that you line up the decimal
points so once we line up the decimal
points we're ready to start adding but
hey Sal there's something very strange
here you might say how can I add this
five to a nothing well there's a there's
a very easy solution that let's just put
a zero right here how can I do that how
can I just randomly augment a number
with a zero well I don't know if I've
already shown you another module but
when you add trailing zeroes to decimals
it doesn't really change the value of
the decimal and I think that makes sense
to you if I said one point one zero that
that's the same thing as one point 1
which is the same thing as one point one
zero-zero right it's all one and one
tenth and the zero is just kind of add
extra digits of precision which actually
don't change the actual value and maybe
later when I'm teaching you computer
programming and computation the
precision might matter but for now it
doesn't it's just the value so I added
this zero here you can always do that
you can add trailing zeroes without
actually changing the value of the
number and now we're really ready to add
five plus zero is five eight plus nine
is 17 1 plus zero plus 9 is 10 carry the
1 1 plus zero plus 7 is 8 and then bring
down this one right because it's nothing
to add it to and we could have even
added a leading zero here if you wanted
to my wife's a doctor and she says it's
key that you always had that leading
zero so that no one gives someone the
wrong amount of medicine but anyway so
now we are almost done we've done the
addition and now we have to figure out
where to put the decimal point well the
decimal point just dropped straight down
we're able to do that because we already
lined up the decimal points so the
answer to this problem is one point
eight zero seven five it seems
complicated but all you have to do line
up the decimal point add zeros where
appropriate and add and if you know how
to add you already know how to do this
let's do another problem
58 point seven five plus 0.02 8 now if I
if you saw a problem like this I've
written in this format your temptation
might be to immediately start adding add
the 5 to the a the seven two to eight to
zero and then just bring down the five
or something of that nature and you
would be wrong and and I think you
realize why you'd be wrong because you
forgot the first step the first step is
line up the decimal points when you're
doing addition with decimals the number
one step is line up the decimal points
so let's line up the decimal points so
we can just rewrite that top number
again 58 0.75
and now let's rewrite the bottom number
so that the decimal points line up so
we'll put the decimal points right below
it and it's point zero two eight and now
we can add and just like before you
might say well how can I add nothing to
this eight we can add a trailing zero to
this top number because it really
doesn't change the value of the number
and now it kind of gives us a sense of
security we have something to add to the
eight so let's do that
zero plus eight is eight five plus two
is seven 7 plus zero is seven eight plus
blank space is eight and we could have
at a zero there and it'd have been the
same thing and the leading zero we
wouldn't have given someone the wrong
amount of medicine five plus blank space
is five and we just drop down that
decimal point and we're done
it's that straightforward you line up
the decimal points add any zeros that
might make you feel more comfortable
because it's often more comfortable to
add to a zero than to add to a blank
space and then you do your addition and
then you drop down the decimal point the
answer is 58 point seven seven eight and
it's always good to kind of do a reality
check to say well does my answer make
sense I have 58 point seven five so
roughly 58 almost 59 58 and three
quarters and I'm adding a very small
number to it I'm adding 0.028 so my
answer shouldn't shouldn't change much I
guess the way I could view it it should
still be around 58 something because I'm
only adding a very small amount if you
had done it this way and you had just
started adding immediately you would
have gotten some you would have gotten
59 point something you're like boy but I
only added point O to eight not 0.28 and
you've been a little bit suspicious of
your answer I hope I didn't confuse you
but it's really healthy to always think
about the magnitude of your numbers and
get a feel for just what you are adding
and not always do it a purely mechanical
although sometimes it is fun just to
chug through things put now let's let's
do one more problem just just for for
good measure
some time left on the video 102 point
one plus two point five six so once
again think about magnitude 102.1 plus
two point five six that should be like
104 point something I won't do it in my
head we'll do it on paper so first thing
we line up the decimal points 102.1
plus line up the decimal points two
point five six now we can add a trailing
zero here and we're ready to add 0 plus
6 is 6
1 plus 5 is 6 2 plus 2 is 4 0 plus
nothing is 0 1 plus nothing is 1 bring
down that decimal point 104 point six
six it was that easy
hopefully it's easy I don't want to make
you think that it's easy if you're
finding it hard because it actually is
hard the first time you do it but anyway
I think you're ready now to try the
module on adding decimals I I hope you
have fun